the next award will be for the best  actress and I am pleased to announce  that this year in addition to the Oscar  the winning actress will also receive  three glorious days at the Sands Hotel  in Las Vegas  to make to make the presentations last  year's winner for this his provocative  performance and judgment at Nuremburg  ladies and gentlemen mr. maximilian  schell  thank you  the nominees for Best Performance by an  actress are Anne Bancroft and the  miracle worker Betty Davis in whatever  happened to Baby Jane Katharine Hepburn  in long day's journey into night  Geraldine page and sweet bird of youth  and Lee Remick in days of wine and roses  and the winner is Anne Bancroft  accepting for Anne Bancroft miss Joan  Crawford  miss miss Bancroft said here is my  little speech dear Joan quote there are  three reasons why I deserve this award  Arthur Penn bill Gibson Fred Cole  unquote thank you  Oh